Grazie.
Entrai nella scuola trent'anni orsono, quando la legge mi domandava solo che insegnassi la storia con spirito di verità e di lealtà, non che vendessi la mia anima al partito dominante.
Oggi la Costituzione politica italiana di trent'anni orsono è completamente abolita. Oggi l'Italia è divisa fra una minoranza di padroni armati, a cui tutto è lecito, anche l'assassinio, ed una moltitudine di sudditi disarmati, non più protetti da nessuna legge morale, esclusi da ogni diritto politico.
Non sono parole mie, voi lo capite, sono le parole con cui Gaetano Salvemini, da Parigi, nel dicembre 1925, scrive al rettore dell'Università di Firenze per informarlo che si dimette, rinuncia alla cattedra e non tornerà in Italia.
Gaetano Salvemini è il protagonista di questo primo incontro, il primo di questi tre incontri di quest'anno e io vorrei cominciare dicendo due parole brevissime sulla scelta dell'argomento di quest'anno.
Voi capite che parlarvi della responsabilità dello storico per uno che fa il mio mestiere ha un significato particolare.
Quest'anno il tema del Festival della Mente è la responsabilità e io vi racconterò tre storici del Novecento,
nella cui vita il mestiere dello storico e la responsabilità del cittadino si sono intrecciati in modi che la nostra generazione non ha più dovuto affrontare,
per fortuna, sostanzialmente per fortuna, però come vedrete, come spero che vedrete, i risultati sono tre vite incredibili di tre uomini che non sono stati soltanto grandi storici
e questo può interessare a me e a chi fa il mio mestiere perché i loro libri sono tuttora dei punti di riferimento,
ma potrebbero non essere degli storici e le loro tre vite, come vedrete, sarebbe la stessa cosa,
varrebbe lo stesso la pena di raccontarle per attraversare con loro il Novecento.
Stasera Gaetano Salvemini, un nome che io poi mi sono chiesto quanto ci è familiare ancora oggi,
ma il nome sì, certo, un grande intellettuale di una volta, poi però forse non più così presente,
tanto che è importante, prima di cominciare a raccontare la vita di Salvemini,
avere chiaro che lui alla sua epoca, e quindi direi per tutta la prima metà del Novecento,
è stato un uomo famosissimo, è stato un intellettuale e un politico celeberrimo,
conosciutissimo in Italia e anche all'estero,
in modi che oggi non riusciamo neanche più a immaginarci,
vedrete che ci sono dei motivi per questo, ma tenetelo presente,
parliamo di un uomo che quando interveniva l'Italia lo stava a sentire,
fino a quando l'Italia non ha minacciato di rompergli la testa a manganellate
e lo ha costretto ad andare all'estero.
Allora, Gaetano Salvemini nasce a Molfetta,
è un pugliese quindi, nel 1873,
è il secondo di nove figli,
le belle famiglie di una volta,
in realtà erano dodici figli,
i nove sono quelli sopravvissuti,
e il secondo, primo maschio di questi nove figli,
nasce da una famiglia della piccolissima borghesia,
il papà fa l'istitutore in un collegio,
il maestro per intenderci.
In famiglia c'è anche, classico di una volta,
lo zio prete,
dal quale Salvemini Gaetanino comincia a imparare qualche cosa,
i primi rudimenti di latino glieli insegna lo zio prete,
siamo negli anni 70 dell'Ottocento,
lo zio prete però è anche borbonico,
e lì Gaetano Bambino comincia a imparare
che la storia può essere una cosa più controversa
di quello che magari lui credeva,
perché Gaetano Bambino di quarta elementare,
sì, sì, quarta elementare,
torna a casa un giorno tutto entusiasta,
raccontando che a scuola il maestro
ha spiegato l'impresa dei mille,
e Garibaldi,
e lui racconta questa cosa a tavola,
con tutta la famiglia a tavola,
senza accorgersi che cade il gelo tutto intorno,
fino a quando lo zio prete borbonico
non prende la parola
e annuncia a Gaetano che lui e il maestro
andranno all'inferno.
È una famiglia della piccolissima borghesia,
si è elevata di un gradino rispetto ai nonni contadini,
però allevare nove figli con lo stipendio di un maestro
nell'italietta di fine Ottocento
vuol dire la miseria.
E come tanti, nelle stesse condizioni,
Gaetanino, per andare a scuola,
innanzitutto va in seminario
e studia a lungo in seminario
e lì fa due scoperte
che poi più tardi scriverà
queste due cose,
questi due libri
mi hanno influenzato in modo decisivo.
Sentite lo storico Salvemini,
quali sono i due libri
da cui è stato influenzato fin da bambino.
Il primo libro della geometria di Euclide
Miracolo di chiarezza,
ordine, buonsenso
ebbe un'influenza decisiva e permanente
sul mio sviluppo intellettuale.
L'altro libro è la Bibbia
che naturalmente da buon cattolico in casa
non aveva mai letto
deve andare in seminario
perché gli facciano leggere la Bibbia
e la Bibbia lo impressiona.
La Bibbia dice
i Vangeli in particolare
con la loro potenza morale
e bellezza poetica
dettero al mio pensiero
un grande graffio
che rimase.
Ora voi capite
uno che fa lo storico
perché è attrezzato così
perché ha letto Euclide
e ha letto la Bibbia.
Potremmo dire
c'è una vecchia domanda
che ossessiona noi storici
Mark Bloch diceva
che è stupido
di perdere tempo dietro a queste cose.
La storia è un'arte
o è una scienza?
Ecco
Salvemini evidentemente
non sentiva la contraddizione.
Euclide
è la Bibbia
per la poesia
della Bibbia.
Bene
dunque fa il liceo
arriva a prendere
la maturità
in seminario
e poi
e poi andare all'università
è proibitivo
ma Salvemini
vince una borsa di studio
e con quella borsa
di studio
riesce ad andare
all'università
di Firenze
60 lire al mese
abbastanza per campare
ma proprio
tirato tirato
durante queste lezioni
spesso vi citerò direttamente
come vedete
sto già facendo
le parole
degli studiosi
che vi racconto
che sapevano tutti
maneggiare la penna
ogni tanto mi sono detto
è comodo anche
parlo più con le parole loro
che con le mie
quando esagero
ditemelo
ma
secondo me è importante
sentire la loro voce
senza quelle
60 lire
avrei dovuto
tornarmene al mio paese
primo maschio
di nove fratelli
e sorelle
a diventar prete
che questo era
nell'Italia meridionale
di allora
il destino
dei ragazzi
non stupidi
di famiglie povere
e invece lo scampa
c'è la borsa di studio
va all'università di Firenze
a studiare storia
per un attimo
ha un dubbio
fra i suoi compagni
all'università di Firenze
c'è Cesare Battisti
quello che poi sarà
il martire dell'irredentismo
e c'è una ragazza
che poi sposerà
Cesare Battisti
ma che evidentemente
anche a Gaetano piaceva
la ragazza studia filosofia
e Salvemini dice
per un momento
ho esitato
io
vi racconto questa cosa
in queste tre serate
raccontandovi tre storici
inevitabilmente
vi racconto anche
diciamo
qualcosa di me
e qualcosa che ci accomuna
tutti bene o male
trovando l'occasione
in questo caso
nelle idee di Salvemini
non sono quindi io
che lo dico
però non posso
non confessare
che trovo una certa affinità
con l'idea di Salvemini
che dice
ho rischiato
di diventare un filosofo
ci fu un momento
che pensai di lasciare
la storia per la filosofia
fortunatamente
guarì
da quella scarlattina
prima che mi rovinasse
studierà storia
il suo maestro
è un importante storico
di allora
Pasquale Villari
che gli insegna
tante cose
gli insegna
che la storia
è una roba viva
non è una roba morta
che la storia
è contatto
fra il passato
e il presente
e soprattutto
dice ancora Salvemini
ci insegnava
soprattutto
a non essere mummie
a essere uomini
bene
ma all'università
a Gaetano Salvemini
capita anche un'altra cosa
che scopre la politica
e diventa socialista
o
capiamoci
siamo nell'Italia
degli anni 1890
il partito comunista
non esiste ancora
il partito socialista
è l'estrema sinistra
fa parte dell'internazionale
è visto con spavento
dai borghesi
è un partito rivoluzionario
anche se più nelle teorie
che nella prassi
Salvemini
ventenne
è nato nel 73
Salvemini ventenne
all'università di Firenze
e poi dopo
è un estremista
è un rivoluzionario
ricordiamoci
cosa sono
gli anni 90
dell'ottocento
in Italia
sono non solo
gli anni in cui
si sta uscendo
con gran fatica
dalla crisi economica
di fine ottocento
ma proprio con grande fatica
sono ancora anni
di crisi pesante
e sono anni
di crisi politica
da un lato
il paese
si avventura
nelle imprese
coloniali
e ci prendiamo
la batosta
di Adua
la più grande
figuraccia
di un esercito
europeo
nelle colonie
ma il peggio
è che in Italia
c'è una svolta
reazionaria
pesantissima
l'atmosfera
negli anni 90
è molto pesante
sono quelli
che vengono chiamati
i governi
della sciabola
quando in piazza
l'esercito spara
e la cavalleria
carica
gli scioperanti
sono gli anni
dei moti di Milano
del 1898
con il generale
Bava Beccaris
che fa sparare
sulla folla
a Milano
e fa centinaia
di morti
nelle strade
di Milano
il tutto sotto
la copertura
del re Umberto
che non per niente
nel 1900
un anarchico
ammazzerà
talmente
una parte del paese
non ne può più
di quello che sta succedendo
allora in questi anni
Gaetanino
ventenne
studente universitario
è un estremista
rivoluzionario
e non ne può più
di questo partito
socialista
vi stupirà
i partiti della sinistra
in Italia
hanno una certa tendenza
a scivolare
poi pian piano
sempre più
verso il centro
dello schieramento
politico
già allora
il partito socialista
è governato
è guidato da uomini
come Turati
i quali
Gaetano Salvemini
morde il freno
c'è la piazza
che ribolle
c'è l'esercito
che spara
ci sarebbe
l'occasione
di fare la rivoluzione
e invece
Turati frena
il partito
frena
Salvemini
da giovane
dice cose
di questo tipo
smettere
la tattica
legale
e mettersi
sulle vie
rivoluzionarie
star quieti
organizzarsi
ferreamente
sembra Lenin
poi Lenin
è andato avanti dritto
Salvemini
come vedremo
a certo punto
cambia idea
non dar pretesto
a reazioni
con moti
inconsulti
e preparare
la rivoluzione
vera
e non
la rivolta
buona
soltanto
a far guadagnare
medaglie
agli scappati
da Adwa
cioè
un esercito
che ad Adwa
ha fatto
quel che ha fatto
ma in Italia
fa il coraggioso
e spara
in questi anni
Salvemini
fa una
estremista
ovviamente
giovane
pieno di
fantasie
di idealismi
fa anche una riflessione
estremamente lucida
sulla legalità
cos'è la legalità
perché voi capite
nel partito socialista
i capi dicono
no no
un momento
si sta nella legalità
e Salvemini dice
ci sono due tipi
di legalità
una volta
la legalità
voleva dire
la volontà
del padrone
quella è la legge
oggi
c'è un senso
moderno
della legalità
la volontà
del popolo
come fonte
della legge
e Salvemini
120 anni fa
dice
i governi
d'oggi
in teoria
si basano
sulla legalità
moderna
la volontà
del popolo
ma in pratica
adorano ancora
sempre la legalità
antica
e cercano
in tutti i modi
di praticarla
la legalità
antica
cioè la volontà
del padrone
e la gente
deve ubbidire
specialmente
dove i sudditi
non sono pronti
a picchiare
questa idea
che quando ce n'è bisogno
bisogna saper picchiare
perché altrimenti
lo stato
ti schiaccia
è un'idea
che negli anni
a Salvemini
sembra una cosa
addirittura
ovvia
oh questo estremismo
giovanile
svanirà presto
un altro aspetto
del Salvemini
politico
invece rimarrà
sempre
Salvemini
è un meridionale
e la questione
meridionale
è centrale
nell'Italia
di allora
come poi sarà
sempre centrale
in Italia
Salvemini
ci lavora su
ci ragiona su
e si convince
di una cosa
la soluzione
per il sud
dove i mali
sono l'immobilismo
e la corruzione
politica
la soluzione
è che bisogna
portare alla politica
le masse
le masse contadine
dei contadini
del sud
sono loro
che devono
prendere in mano
il loro destino
non ci si può
aspettare niente
dallo Stato
lo Stato italiano
non farà mai nulla
come non ha fatto
finora
mai nulla
nel partito
socialista
gli amici
gli dicono
ma calma
non vedi che c'è
un processo
comunque
di democratizzazione
in corso
e la democrazia
sarà la soluzione
Salvemini
pensa che la democrazia
non basti
succederà
alla democrazia
quel che è successo
prima alla destra
e poi alla sinistra
fuori
una facciata
liberale
e dentro
la verminaia
delle camorre
del nord
e del sud
così Salvemini
sull'Italia
del 1900
qual è il modo
per portare
le masse contadine
alla coscienza politica
Salvemini
si convince
che il modo è uno
il suffragio universale
bisogna che votino
perché non votano
naturalmente
qual è la situazione
del suffragio
alla fine dell'ottocento
in Italia
che i limiti
economici
censitari
sono stati
in gran parte
rimossi
ma rimane
un vincolo fortissimo
gli analfabeti
non votano
per votare
devi andarti
a registrare
e far vedere
che sai scrivere
di conseguenza
la massa
dei contadini
del sud
non vota
Salvemini
si impegna
nel partito
socialista
a lottare
per ottenere
il suffragio
universale
maschile
si intende
allora
non gli veniva in mente
a quasi nessuno
che potesse
voler dire
un'altra cosa
ma quello
maschile
sì
ora
pensate
l'effetto
dirompente
che ha
questa cosa
proporre
il suffragio
universale
in un'Italia
dove in certe
zone
siccome
non vota
quasi nessuno
i voti
sono pochi
e quindi
scopre
Salvemini
non si deve
spendere molto
per fare
eleggere
un deputato
non ci sono
molti voti
da comprare
in un suo articolo
Salvemini
cita quel sindaco
di un paesino
della Calabria
che gli diceva
ma tu vuoi fare
il suffragio
universale
ma ragiona
un po'
i voti
qui in paese
si pagano
fino a 300 lire
e perciò
bisogna andare
molto cauti
nell'aumentare
il numero
degli elettori
dopodiché
Salvemini
scopre anche
un'altra cosa
ancora più
sorprendente
che nemmeno
il partito
socialista
ci tiene
tanto
al suffragio
universale
e il partito
socialista
non ci tiene
tanto
perché gli operai
del nord
ormai
sempre più
spesso
sanno
leggere
e scrivere
e quindi
votano
e al giovane
Salvemini
gli dicono
ma sei sicuro
che ci conviene
far votare
anche i tuoi
contadini
del sud
non è che poi
votano
come gli dice
il prete
ricordate
i dubbi
che ci saranno
poi più tardi
una generazione
dopo
per il voto
alle donne
anche a sinistra
non è che poi
ecco
stessa cosa
qui
Salvemini
spiega
ai compagni
socialisti
del nord
che non sanno
niente
di cos'è
il sud
al sud
dice
i preti
sono odiati
perché sono visti
come alleati
dei padroni
dei galantuomini
di conseguenza
la gente va a messa
ma poi
non rispetta
minimamente
il prete
dunque
Salvemini
si impegna
in queste battaglie
politiche
o naturalmente
nel frattempo
si è laureato
ed essendosi
laureato
in lettere
cosa succede
in Italia
a un giovane
appena laureato
in lettere
che gli danno subito
la cattedra a scuola
come è normale
nei primissimi anni
come si usa allora
lo mandano a tappare
i buchi
in diverse città
dove al liceo
c'è un posto libero
e allora
da un anno all'altro
Salvemini
si fa
Palermo
Faenza
Lodi
Firenze
sembrano cose
molto attuali
ben inteso
tutto questo
col posto garantito
però
in cattedra
e nei primissimi anni
dopo la laurea
Salvemini
si butta a corpo morto
non ha mai fatto niente
credo
senza buttarci
sia a corpo morto
il giovanissimo
professor Salvemini
si butta a corpo morto
nei problemi
della scuola
e dopo un po'
comincia a scrivere
articoli di denuncia
dicendo sostanzialmente
voi riderete
la scuola pubblica
è in miseria
non ci sono soldi
gli stipendi
sono miserabili
l'opinione pubblica
è indifferente
e quando i professori
protestano
l'opinione pubblica
tende anzi
a essere ostile
Salvemini
all'inizio
è ancora molto rivoluzionario
sono le ultime cose
molto rivoluzionarie
che vi leggo
dallo stile di Salvemini
all'inizio
dice proprio
si si vede
certo
lo Stato
lo Stato non vuole
allo Stato
non importa niente
della scuola pubblica
sentite questa
questa è proprio l'ultima
e devo dire
poi diventa più moderato
per i partiti conservatori
le colonne della società
non sono né il maestro elementare
né l'insegnante secondario
né l'insegnante d'università
le colonne della società
sono il prete
il magistrato
il militare
l'uomo che inganna
l'uomo che condanna
l'uomo che uccide
dopo di che
Salvemini
vive in un'Italia
guardate bene
siamo prima
del concordato
quella è un'Italia
che in teoria
è un paese
laico
lo Stato non italiano
non è neanche riconosciuto
dal Vaticano
non c'è la lezione
di religione
i crocifissi
nelle aule
non c'è niente
di tutto questo
c'è addirittura
qualcuno
che dice
non dovremmo neanche
permettere ai preti
di avere delle scuole
Salvemini
che è un anticlericale
impenitente
e coerentissimo
fino alla morte
di un anticlericalismo
estremo
io ho dovuto tagliare
vi potrei leggere
certi passi
di quel che pensa
vabbè
è un anticlericale
feroce
però sul fatto
della scuola privata
non ha dubbi
guai se non lasciamo
che ci siano
le scuole private
se lo Stato
pretendesse di avere
il monopolio della scuola
sarebbe come pretendere
il monopolio
della stampa
ecco
guai
detto questo
Salvemini
si fa l'idea
era uno che si faceva
in fretta delle idee
quando gli sembrava
gli aver capito
la situazione
non aveva scrupole
a metterla giù
Salvemini dice
sì saremo anche
un paese laico
ma qui in realtà
la classe dirigente
è clericale
sotto sotto
e allora
Salvemini scrive
nell'anno di Grazia
questo brano
che non riesco
a resistere
al citarvi adesso
per farvi vedere
quanto era diversa
l'Italia di allora
la politica scolastica
del partito clericale
non può essere
in Italia
che una sola
deprimere la scuola pubblica
non far nulla
per migliorarla
e più largamente
dotarla
favorire le scuole
private
confessionali
con sussidi
pubblici
e con sedi
d'esami
con pareggiamenti
rafforzata
poco a poco
la scuola
privata
confessionale
e disorganizzata
la scuola pubblica
sopprimere
questa
al momento opportuno
e presentare
come unica
salvatrice
della gioventù
quella
dopodiché
la cosa che veramente
lo colpisce
lo coinvolge
è la miseria
degli insegnanti
su questo fatto
che gli insegnanti
sono pagati
scandalosamente
poco
oh ben inteso
è puro caso
vuole che noi
in questi giorni
in Italia
stiamo parlando
molto di scuola
di insegnanti
eccetera
qui io vi sto citando
appunto
ci sono tutte le fonti
cose degli anni
Salvemini
pubblica delle cose
sulla situazione
degli insegnanti
nell'Italia
di allora
che sono di un'estrema lucidità
l'insegnante
guadagna troppo poco
all'inizio parte
con tanto entusiasmo
e poi
pian piano
l'entusiasmo
si spegne
passano gli anni
le forze diminuiscono
ci sono le lezioni
private da dare
e alla fine
l'insegnante
va a scuola
per guadagnarsi
lo stipendio
e basta
e si risparmia
per dare le lezioni
private
poi fuori orario
e dice
Salvemini
quando poi
si azzarda
a protestare
l'opinione pubblica
gli dice
ma cosa volete
ancora voi
altri insegnanti
secondo Salvemini
l'opinione pubblica
italiana
pensa
nel 1905
che l'insegnante
vive in un mondo
ideale
dove non ha
bisogni
non ha preoccupazioni
non ha dolori
e si nutre solo
di bacche
dall'oro
e di cipresso
come fare
per cambiare qualcosa
Salvemini
fa una cosa
che di nuovo
poi parleremo
di cose inattuali
l'interventismo
della prima guerra
mondiale
eccetera
ma qui colpisce
vedere
quest'uomo
che di fronte
a questi problemi
a un certo punto
trova la soluzione
dobbiamo fare
un sindacato
anche noi
lo fa nel 1902
Salvemini
fonda il sindacato
degli insegnanti
anche qui
tenete presente
cos'è l'epoca
i sindacati
sono cose
che al bravo
borghese
fanno paura
che organizzano
solo gli operai
e che
organizzano
gente
vista con sospetto
sono rivendicazioni
sospette
dire agli insegnanti
che sono appena
arrivati a questa
condizione
piccolo borghese
finalmente
anche loro
figli di contadini
che devono fare
un sindacato
è una cosa
che nell'Italia
di allora
è abbastanza
scioccante
Salvemini
ci si impegna
e
un'altra sua
caratteristica
che tendeva
a illudersi
fonda il sindacato
degli insegnanti
e nel programma
dice
noi
non dobbiamo andare
a elemosinare
non dobbiamo
formare una
confraternita
di pitocchi
non dobbiamo
usare il tipico
sistema italiano
del pianisteo
dobbiamo
imporre
all'opinione
pubblica
il problema
della scuola
dobbiamo
imporre
all'attenzione
dell'opinione
pubblica
e quindi
del governo
il problema
della scuola
era un uomo
che per tutta la vita
si è fatto un sacco
di illusioni
Gaetano Salvemini
e lo vedremo
anche più avanti
oh
parentesi
ma non tanto
questo giovanotto
nel 1899
a 26 anni
pubblica
un grandissimo
libro di storia
medievale
perché è pur sempre
uno storico
l'uomo di cui vi sto
parlando
e
dormiva poco
la notte
evidentemente
oltre a far
politica
oltre a fare
il sindacato
oltre a insegnare
continua i suoi studi
pubblica
la tesi di laurea
e poi
nel 1899
a 26 anni
pubblica
un grandissimo libro
di storia medievale
che si chiama
Magnati e Popolani
a Firenze
all'epoca di Dante
ora
io mi sono chiesto a lungo
preparando queste lezioni
ma fin dove
posso andare
a raccontare
dell'attività
di storici
di questi personaggi
non posso esagerare
ovviamente
però al tempo stesso
sono storici
e una vaga idea
del perché
sono grandi
storici
mi sembra
che devo darla
perciò io
su questo
vi faccio
un medaglione
diciamo così
Magnati e Popolani
a 26 anni
Salvemini
studia
un comune medievale
un grandissimo
comune medievale
dove ovviamente
ci sono delle feroci
lotte politiche
Guelfi e Ghibellini
e Magnati e Popolani
per l'appunto
alla sua epoca
sembrava scontato
che i Guelfi e Ghibellini
si sa cosa sono
i Guelfi
sono quelli
che vogliono il Papa
i Ghibellini
sono quelli
che vogliono
l'imperatore
e siccome
alla sua epoca
anche qui
i paraocchi ideologici
che noi abbiamo
nel nostro mestiere
in ogni momento
cosa pensate
che interessasse
alla cultura italiana
a fine ottocento
del Medioevo
l'unità d'Italia
la spinta
verso l'unità d'Italia
questo loro cercavano
nel passato
e quindi pensavano
i Guelfi
sono quelli
che vogliono fare
l'unità d'Italia
sotto il Papa
i Ghibellini
sono quelli
che vogliono fare
l'unità d'Italia
sotto l'imperatore
questa teoria
è sbagliata
da cima a fondo
Guelfi e Ghibellini
sono partiti
locali
che combattono
per ragioni
locali
indipendenti
dalla lotta
tra Papa e Imperatore
alla libertà
all'indipendenza
alla unità italiana
ai diritti
del Papato
o dell'Impero
essi non ci pensano
nemmeno
ed è una cosa
verissima
appena ci hai pensato
e vai a vedere
te ne accorgi
sono interessi locali
fazioni rivali
ma bisognava
avere la lucidità
di vederlo
quando tutti gli altri
vedevano un'altra cosa
questa capacità
di superare
i paraocchi ideologici
del proprio tempo
è la cosa
che distingue
un grande storico
dagli altri
salvo che poi
naturalmente
anche il grande storico
vive nel suo tempo
e magari cade
in altri paraocchi
per Salvemini
26enne
non dimentichiamocelo mai
quando scrive
questo libro
per Salvemini
26enne
rivoluzionario
quello che conta
è la lotta di classe
e quindi lui
cerca di spiegare
la vita politica
dei comuni medievali
come lotta fra classi
in parte cia zecca
in parte meno
lui vede quello
qualcuno che lo accusa
di semplicismo
c'è
un famoso intellettuale
italiano di allora
Vilfredo Pareto
il teorico delle elite
che la lotta di classe
non l'amava
particolarmente
come nella sua concezione
c'è una lettera
di un amico di Salvemini
che gli scrive
e gli dice
ho parlato di te
con Vilfredo Pareto
e Pareto mi ha detto
quel tuo amico
mi pare avere
una fissazione
con la sua lotta
di classe
se piove
sarà per cagione
della lotta
di classe
come dire
che appunto
ognuno di noi
poi si crea
i suoi paraocchi
il suo modo
di vedere le cose
però
l'abbiamo portato
solo fino a 26 anni
di vita
questo ragazzo
e a 28
nel 1901
l'Italia di allora
è anche questo
per questo grande libro
gli danno
una cattedra
universitaria
gli danno
la cattedra
all'università
di Messina
nel frattempo
ha anche fatto
quell'altra cosa
che è normale
fare
ti sei laureato
hai cominciato
a lavorare
ti sposi
a 24 anni
si è sposato
si è trovato
anche un'altra
pugliese
residente a Firenze
perché evidentemente
uno poi cerca
comunque
delle affinità
ha sposato
Maria
Minervini
hanno fatto
5 figli
e dunque
a 28 anni
prende la sua cattedra
all'università
di Messina
si trasferisce
lì con la famiglia
fin qua
capite
in una lettera
del 1908
scrive
nella mia vita
privata
sono così felice
che ho persino
paura
ora io non so
se a qualcuno
di voi
il luogo
e la data
che ho citato
fanno scattare
qualcosa
nella memoria
ha avuto
la cattedra
a Messina
e nel 1908
scrive
sono così felice
che ho persino
paura
e poi
alle 5 del mattino
del 28 dicembre
il terremoto
rade al suolo
Messina
e Reggio
dall'altra parte
Salvemini
è appena tornato
a casa
era fuori
in viaggio
è appena tornato
è sveglio
alle 5 del mattino
sente la prima
scossa di terremoto
va alla finestra
in quel momento
l'intera parete
della casa
va giù
e lui è dentro
la finestra
è protetto
dall'architrave
della finestra
arriva giù
dal quinto piano
e si salva
quando rinviene
e si guarda
indietro
non c'è più
casa sua
e non c'è più
la città di Messina
nel terremoto
di Messina
Salvemini
perde la moglie
tutti e 5
i figli
e la sorella
che in quel momento
si trovava con loro
voi capite
qui non ci sarebbe
più niente da dire
è una roba tale
che non si può descrivere
e quindi voi
mi scuserete
se io a questo punto
introduco una nota
non dico comica
ma quasi surreale
non si sa
se Salvemini
è morto oppure no
e Salvemini
è già così famoso
in Italia
come socialista
come storico
che un po'
dappertutto
in Italia
mentre si piangono
le vittime
e si fa il conto
dei morti
si parla di Salvemini
che è successo
a Salvemini
non lo trovano più
Turati
capo del partito
socialista
scrive
due o tre giorni
dopo il terremoto
quando non sa ancora
se Salvemini
è vivo o morto
e dice
Salvemini
il più colto
il più armato
dei socialisti italiani
io vi confesso
che la prima volta
che ho letto questa frase
il mio cervello
mi ha fatto leggere
il più colto
il più amato
mi sembrava così bello
funzionava perfettamente
no?
poi sono dovuto andare
a rileggere
no?
dice il più armato
perché per Salvemini
la cultura è
indiscutibilmente
un'arma
e questo è quello
che vuol dire
Turati
era quello
più capace
di combattere
di tutti
era
forse è
ma Turati
non lo sa
un altro
leader socialista
che va per la maggiore
in quel momento
è più sbrigativo
scrive un telegramma
di condoglianze
al suocero di Salvemini
con Gaetano Salvemini
scompare
una delle più belle figure
del socialismo italiano
firmato
Benito Mussolini
ma non sono solo
i socialisti
è tutta la cultura
italiana
angosciata
per la sorte
di questo
che ormai non è più
un ragazzo
per carità
35 anni
Benedetto Croce
quando ormai
Salvemini è venuto fuori
l'hanno trovato
Benedetto Croce
in una lettera scrive
il disastro di Messina
ci ha gettati
nell'angoscia
e nel lutto
avevo tanti amici
colà
il Salvemini
vi ha perduto
tutta la famiglia
e fa temere
per la sua ragione
dopodiché
dopo di che
Salvemini reagisce
nell'unico modo
che riesce a immaginare
si butta nel lavoro
si butta nella politica
dopo due mesi
Salvemini
scrive a un altro
grande intellettuale
suo amico
Prezzolini
io mi sono rimesso
al lavoro
e vedo
con gioia
e con terrore
che mi interessa
capite questo
con gioia
e con terrore
perché comunque
ho ancora motivo
di vivere
e però con terrore
perché se due mesi
dopo
quello che mi è successo
mi accordo
che mi rimetto
sui miei documenti
e mi interessa
ma chi sono io
allora
cioè
gli viene da chiederselo
dopodiché
più tardi
scriverà una volta
a Salvemini
si mi vedono
che lavoro
faccio politica
sembro forte
non sanno
che sono
un poveretto
da vecchio
gli capiterà
da dire
che ha passato
tutta la vita
pensando al suicidio
dopodiché
non si suicida
e si butta
nella politica italiana
che nel frattempo
è cambiata
perché la politica
del 1909
non è più quella
dei Bava Beccaris
e dei Cannoni
non c'è più
il re Umberto
c'è Vittorio Emanuele
non ci sono più
i governi
della Sciabola
e c'è Giolitti
e l'epoca giolittiana
il primo decennio
il primo quindicennio
del secolo
quando noi
la riguardiamo oggi
è un'epoca
in cui l'Italia
cresce
cresce in democrazia
e cresce in economia
comincia la rivoluzione
industriale
nelle città del nord
nasce la Fiat
Salvemini
si butta in politica
ma lui pensa al sud
pensa al mezzogiorno
e buttandosi in politica
voglio dire
che accetta di fare
il candidato
si presenta alle elezioni
fa campagna elettorale
nel sud
e lì scopre
l'altra faccia
della medaglia
qui fuori
vendono uno dei suoi libri
il ministro della malavita
andatelo a leggere
è Giolitti
che nella storia d'Italia
è passato come il ministro
modernizzatore
che ha concesso molto
anche al movimento operaio
e così via
Salvemini dice
l'altra faccia
della medaglia
è che
Giolitti
si regge
su una maggioranza
eletta soprattutto
al sud
e al sud
voi non vi immaginate
dice ai lettori
dei giornali del nord
come avvengono
le elezioni
e il quadro
che dà
Salvemini
in questo libro
del 1910
il ministro
della malavita
è stupefacente
e noi l'abbiamo
credo molto rimosso
io non avevo
la minima idea
che le cose fossero
a quel livello
in una parte del paese
Salvemini
rappresenta
la cronaca
di queste elezioni
in piccole città
in cui
i giorni
delle elezioni
la città
è pattugliata
dai picchiatori
da squadre
di picchiatori
col manganello
che vanno in giro
e se trovano
un elettore
antigovernativo
lo pestano
lo cacciano fuori
per cui gli elettori
degli altri partiti
stanno chiusi in casa
il giorno delle elezioni
oppure scappano
dalla città
e la polizia
non solo
chiude un occhio
se qualcuno
protesta
arrestano
chi protesta
io non scradevo
i miei occhi
ripeto
il libro è laggiù
potete andarlo
a sfogliare
sui nostri scaffali
è sbalorditivo
Salvemini
si dà
un altro compito
nella vita
star dietro
a Giolitti
e denunciare
tutte queste
malefatte
sistematicamente
usando le armi
dello storico
raccogliendo
i documenti
intervistando
pubblicando
i fatti
comincia a farlo
con questo libro
e poi continua
a farlo
in un modo
così sistematico
che a me
ha fatto venire in mente
un personaggio
che conosciamo bene oggi
vent'anni dopo
Salvemini
verrà da riassumere
il suo conto
aperto con Giolitti
dicendo
io con Giolitti
ho preso un abbonamento
vent'anni fa
e gli sono rimasto fedele
continuo a stargli dietro
e a denunciare
ecco a me ha fatto venire
Marco Travaglio
devo dire in mente
con questa quasi ossessione
alla fine
di andare a denunciare
gli scandali
di cui si viene a conoscenza
dopodiché
Salvemini
meridionale
che denuncia
i problemi del sud
scopre sempre di più
come già con il suffragio universale
no ve lo dicevo
scopre sempre di più
che nel partito socialista
non lo vogliono stare a sentire
quando denunciavo
i metodi di Giolitti
al sud
dice
i compagni del nord
o ci facevano capire
che non credevano
a queste cose
che stavamo esagerando
oppure scrollavano le spalle
e ci dicevano
da noi il governo
non fa così
la colpa non è di Giolitti
è vostra
alla fine
Salvemini
si rende conto
che il partito socialista
non ha nessun interesse
nei contadini del sud
protegge
gli operai del nord
e non guarda oltre
almeno questa è la diagnosi
di Salvemini
nel 1911
esce dal partito socialista
non è più
il rivoluzionario
che era da giovane
ovviamente
sono passate tante cose
è anche successa
un'altra cosa
che ha messo molto
in difficoltà
tutti quanti
che Giolitti
che è una vecchia volpe
ha dato il suffragio universale
senza che glielo chiedessero
il partito socialista
non era tanto convinto
Giolitti l'ha dato
sempre maschile
e si intende
a questo punto
Salvemini
che diventa meno rivoluzionario
e un po' più illuso
forse
col passare degli anni
Salvemini si dice
è fatta
adesso le masse al sud
votano
basta educarle
Salvemini
ha fatto una sua evoluzione
in questi anni
che lo porta
a non aver più
tanto fiducia
nel fatto che le masse
da sole
riescano a fare delle cose
si è un po' convinto
che l'Italia è un paese
dove la maggioranza
non si muove
dove sono le minoranze
che sanno cosa vogliono
che ottengono qualcosa
e lui si convince
che sì
una minoranza
che sa cosa vuole
può ottenere qualcosa
tante volte scrive
basterebbero dieci
venti uomini
che andassero al sud
a parlare alla gente
a spiegare
a far capire
esce dal partito socialista
rimango solo
non importa
basterebbe che fossimo
in pochi
pochi professori
pochi intellettuali
è una parola nuova
intellettuali
lui le scrive
tra virgolette
basterebbero pochi
intellettuali
che cerchino
di educare
i lavoratori
dicendo sempre
e ad ogni costo
la verità
si butta in questo
ma non ha molto tempo
perché succede
un'altra
stiamo andando avanti
pian pianino
sulla tabella
sull'arco cronologico
di questa vita
che arriverà fino
agli anni 50
poi sarà meglio
che io acceleri
se voglio farla tutta
ma ce lo porteremo
agli anni 50
succede un'altra cosa
che come vedremo
anche nelle storie
che vi racconterò
domani e dopodomani
spezza
la storia dell'Europa
e la vita
di tutti quelli
che ci vivono
scoppia la prima guerra mondiale
e in Italia
bisogna decidere
se andare in guerra
oppure restare neutrali
Salvemini
tanto per cambiare
si fa una sua idea
precisissima
e ci si butta
corpo morto
bisogna entrare
in guerra
c'è tanta gente
sgradevole
che dice la stessa cosa
i nazionalisti
quelli che vogliono
conquistare i Balcani
e così via
ma c'è anche
tanta gente per bene
che dice questa cosa
perché dice
la prima guerra mondiale
o meglio
la guerra mondiale
loro non sanno
che è la prima
la guerra mondiale
contro la Germania
contro l'Austria
contro questi paesi
militaristi
è il modo
per far trionfare
la libertà
la democrazia
farla finita
con questi imperi
con l'elmo chiodato
far trionfare
la civiltà
che poi siamo noi
i popoli latini
naturalmente
gli italiani
i francesi
ecco
Salvemini ci crede
ci crede
si batte per l'entrata
in guerra
e quando l'Italia
entra in guerra
va volontario
è abituato
a un'altra vita
anche se durante
una campagna elettorale
gli hanno sparato
intendiamoci
per cui
ne ha visto anche lui
le sue
però sul carso
deve essere un po'
un'altra cosa
dopo due settimane
di trincea
si ammala
non si ammala
non è che fila via
si ammala seriamente
lo spediscono
in ospedale
e poi quando guarisce
lo congedano
evidentemente
il professor Salvemini
in trincea
non serve a tanto
serve di più
all'università
cosa ha fatto
in quelle settimane
di ospedale
secondo voi
cosa fa uno storico
che ha fatto
due settimane
di guerra in trincea
ha scoperto
qualche cosa
di incredibile
scrive appunti
dicendo poi
scriverò un libro
e la reazione
automatica
è obbligata
dello storico
a cui succede qualcosa
e dovete avere pazienza
siamo tutti fatti così
scriverò un libro
non lo scriverà mai
questo libro
e ci torna spesso
poi in futuro
nella sua vita
a dire sì
io ero convinto
che dovevo scrivere
per spiegare alla gente
tanto per cambiare
no
vabbè io anche sono io
qua
che vabbè
spiegare alla gente
che la guerra
non è come le raccontano
i giornali
che è tutta
un'altra cosa
però poi Salvemini
dice anche
io
quando ci ripenso
mi mette una tale
angoscia
che non ce la faccio
a parlarne
torna all'università
gli danno la cattedra
a Firenze
insegna a Firenze
arriva la fine
della guerra
nel dopoguerra
Salvemini
non vorrei insistere
troppo sulle sue ingenuità
era un uomo
di incredibile intelligenza
però poi
quando uno vede
le cose a posteriori
è facile vedere
le cose
che col senno
di poi
sembrano un po' ingenue
Salvemini si dice
la guerra
ha educato la gente
i combattenti
che hanno imparato
cos'è il sacrificio
la solidarietà
loro
sono i nuovi italiani
nasce un partito
dei combattenti
e Salvemini
si candida
e stavolta
entra in Parlamento
col partito
dei combattenti
elezioni del 19
eletto a Bari
detto fra parentesi
non è cambiato niente
rispetto agli anni
di Giolitti
la campagna elettorale
del 19
di Salvemini
a Bari
è il solito
macello
con tafferugli
bastonate
ci scappa
il morto
salvo che il morto
è il capo
dei picchiatori
nemici
perché anche
gli amici di Salvemini
si sono organizzati
e hanno i bastoni
e i coltelli
e si fa così
la campagna elettorale
del 19
a Bari
ci scappa il morto
poi Salvemini
viene eletto
col partito
dei combattenti
un mese dopo
il collega
eletto con lui
viene denunciato
per connivenza
con un contrabbandiere
di formaggi
cosa di questo genere
Salvemini
comincia a perdere
quest'ultima illusione
che i combattenti
fossero quelli
che avrebbero salvato
l'Italia
ed è sempre più
disilluso
però
però è un maestro
che deve aver avuto
un fascino
un carisma
una capacità
di appassionare
i giovani
incredibili
perché sentite
cosa dice di lui
Piero Gobetti
che è suo allievo
gli è molto vicino
impara da lui
un sacco di cose
prima di cominciare
a far politica
per conto suo
Piero Gobetti
quando conosce
Salvemini
è un genio
me lo immaginavo
proprio così
l'uomo
che sviscera
le questioni
e ti presenta
tutte le soluzioni
in due minuti
definitive
magari un po'
troppo in fretta
diremmo noi
Gobetti
ha vent'anni
evidentemente
ai ventenni
per i ventenni
ci vuole anche questo
poi Gobetti
ha vent'anni
ma è uno
talmente intelligente
che non tarda
a capire
che ci sono
dei risvolti
un anno dopo
il giudizio di Gobetti
su Salvemini
è leggermente cambiato
ma non del tutto
quest'uomo
pur nei suoi limiti
addirittura
spaventevoli
evolutamente
accentuati
e di una lucidità
straordinaria
Gobetti dice
in sostanza
parli con lui
lui ha un'idea
chiara su tutto
sembra quasi infantile
te la spara lì
in due minuti
tu dici
vabbè
non correre tanto
poi ci pensi su
e ti accorgi
che dire qualcosa
di più intelligente
non ci riesci
però
quest'uomo
ormai
è molto disilluso
il partito
dei combattenti
è l'ultima speranza
non ha più voglia
è deputato
fa dei bei discorsi
contro l'imperialismo
italiano
che vuole annettere
la Dalmazia
anche se lì
gli abitanti
sono tutti slavi
i nazionalisti
lo odiano
cominciano a chiamarlo
slavemini
dato che appunto
questo rinnegato
tiene le parti
degli slavi
Mussolini
lo sfida a duello
a un certo punto
non sono più così amici
poi il duello
non si fa
per qualche ragione
tecnica
che non ho potuto
appurare
fa dei bei discorsi
in Parlamento
però è stanco
a un certo punto
comincia a scrivere
scrive a un amico
nell'ottobre del 22
altra epoca fatale
salvemini scrive
sono vecchio
non ho più voglia
che fatica
la politica
a discutere di cose
rumorose
per forza
perché in politica
non si può far altro
non ho voglia
voglia di studiare
la vecchiaia
mi rende così
a 49 anni
notate bene
però
una volta si invecchiava
anche più in fretta
forse perché
è così stanco
salvemini
all'inizio
sottovaluta
il fascismo
questa è una cosa
che colpisce molto
perché salvemini è famoso
anche se non ve ne ho ancora
parlato per niente
di questo aspetto
ma negli ultimi dieci minuti
ve ne parlerò
salvemini è famoso
come antifascista
di primissimo piano
all'inizio
salvemini
come tanti altri
sottovaluta
è uno dei tanti
che dicono
ma figurati
dai
finirà tutto
in tre mesi
come nel finale
della marcia su Roma
avete presente
il film di Monicelli
col re che dice
proviamoli per qualche mese
poi vediamo
salvemini è di quelli
ancora dopo il delitto
Matteotti
si illude
dice ormai
hanno tutti contro
non possono durare
in realtà
voi capite
qui potremmo fare
un esercizio molto interessante
lo facciamo in due minuti
uno che ha le sue esperienze
cosa vede del fascismo
lui dice
ma io i picchiatori
l'ho visti già prima
anche sotto giolitti
spaccavano le teste
non mi sembra
che sia cambiato niente
la vita politica italiana
è stata tutta
una dittatura
e Mussolini
è solo un dittatore
fra gli altri
c'è anche un'altra cosa
che lui non ha mai
mandato giù
il fatto che i socialisti
non gli venivano dietro
che i socialisti
non interessava niente
del sud
non gli interessava niente
dei contadini
del sud
lui i socialisti
ce li ha qui ormai
li sente come una forza
paralizzata
ossificata
e in sostanza dice
capiscono solo le bastonate
e allora forse
non gli fanno tanto male
un po' di bastonata
ai nostri socialisti
arriva anche a pensare
questo
a dire questo
e poi lo stesso
ammette che
che nel caos
dell'Italia
del primo dopoguerra
il bisogno di ordine
era così forte
che perfino a lui
è venuto da dire
ma stiamo a vedere
ma se questi riportano
un po' d'ordine
alla fin fine
non bisogna essere contro
per partito preso
tanto che Mussolini
superata la cosa
del duello
equivoca
e gli offre
di iscriversi
al partito fascista
Salvemini
rifiuta
e pian pianino
apre gli occhi
perché lui
continua a insegnare
e a scrivere
e a opporsi
per esempio
alle annessioni italiane
in Dalmazia
e il fatto
che il Salvemini
è un anti-italiano
e un traditore
della patria
circola
Salvemini
per un po'
pensa di poter
continuare a fare
il suo mestiere
e basta
tener duro
tutt'al più
dice ci ficcheranno
in galera
e pazienza
saremo sempre noi
in realtà il problema
non è il rischio
di essere ficcato
in galera
è che Salvemini
comincia a conoscere
degli episodi
che gli fanno capire
in che paese
sta vivendo
lo invitano in Inghilterra
a fare lezione
a Oxford
chiede il passaporto
non glielo vogliono dare
siccome è il tipino
che avete capito
espatria lo stesso
clandestinamente
e va a fare
le sue conferenze
a Oxford
all'università
di Firenze
gli studenti fascisti
impiantano
una gazzarra
dicendo
se n'è andato
il traditore
adesso non lo facciamo
più tornare
sui muri
di Firenze
compaiono
manifesti
che dichiarano
la scimmia
di Molfetta
non rientrerà
in Italia
ma i manifesti
sono ancora il meno
perché sul quotidiano
letto credo
anche qui
la nazione
a Firenze
sul quotidiano
la nazione
compaiono
articoli
in cui si
invitano
tutti gli studenti
fascisti
dell'università
a tenersi
a disposizione
per quella
azione morale
che nei limiti
della legge
valga
somministrare
al Salvemini
il premio
delle sue opinioni
anti-italiane
e così via
capite la meraviglia
di un quotidiano
che pubblica
questa cosa
somministrare
però nei limiti
della legge
perché ha rinnegato
l'italianità
difende
che succede
succede che Mussolini
è talmente famoso
Salvemini
che sta facendo
lezione a Oxford
nel frattempo
che Mussolini
non vuole grane
lo fa tornare
in Italia
Salvemini
ricomincia
a far lezione
e però
il clima
a quel punto
all'università
di Firenze
è pesantissimo
ci sono testimonianze
che descrivono
il rettore
dell'università
di Firenze
e il sindaco
in un angolo
di un corridoio
che fanno finta
di niente
mentre gli studenti
fascisti
manifestano
contro il Salvemini
Salvemini
si rende conto
e scrive
che ormai
non sono più sicuro
quando esco
per andare
a fare lezione
non sono più sicuro
di tornare a casa
col cranio intatto
in realtà
a bastonarlo
non arrivano
ma intanto
le cose vanno avanti
delitto Matteotti
il 3 gennaio
come sapete
Mussolini
si assume
alla Camera
la responsabilità
del delitto
Matteotti
se il fascismo
è stato
un'associazione
a delinquere
io sono il capo
di questa associazione
a delinquere
questa è la dichiarazione
di Mussolini
con cui mette
di fronte
il Parlamento
al fatto
che ormai
non ce n'è
per nessuno
Salvemini
crea un giornale
clandestino
invitando
alla resistenza
in quel periodo
lui ha fatto così
voi lo capite
ci sono molte testimonianze
di vecchi amici
che gli vengono incontro
ciao Salvemini
ma siccome
quelli hanno aderito
al fascismo
Salvemini gli dice
io non la conosco
e tira dritto
si fa un sacco di amici
come capita
all'Università di Firenze
finalmente
lo scoprono
e lo arrestano
e quei seguono
una meravigliosa storia
all'italiana
giugno 25
arrestato
inizio di luglio
rinvio del processo
e libertà provvisoria
31 luglio
amnistia
per tutti
gli accusati
di reati politici
perché c'è l'amnistia
del 31 luglio
per tirar fuori
gli assassini
di Matteotti
ma intanto
però l'amnistia
si fa in generale
e quindi anche
l'accusa
su Salvemini
cade
e a piede libero
in realtà
la polizia
lo segue
Salvemini
prende un treno
arriva a Milano
i poliziotti
lo seguono
alle tre di notte
alla stazione di Milano
salta su un taxi
poi siamo in piena
lotta di spie
salta su un altro taxi
trova dei colleghi
che lo aspettano
in macchina
fra cui Federico Chabot
e altri grandi storici italiani
partono in macchina
da Milano
arrivano
al piccolo San Bernardo
lui non ha i documenti
ma in qualche modo
passa lo stesso
e lo portano in Francia
da lì scriverà
al rettore
la lettera
di dimissioni
con cui ho cominciato
questa chiacchierata
noi oggi
rischiamo un po'
di sottovalutare
queste cose
sono successe
quindi vuol dire
che non era niente di grave
voi pensate cosa vuol dire
è vero che non tiene più famiglia
però pensate
cosa vuol dire
mollo la cattedra
all'università
me ne vado
all'estero
per carità
è vero
sei famoso
ci sono gli esuli
ti aiuteranno
però
non è una di quelle cose
da sottovalutare
e Salvemini
all'estero
si butta
nell'ultima grande battaglia
della sua vita
controbattere
la propaganda
fascista
che all'estero
ha un'efficacia
enorme
Salvemini
è sempre stato
il primo
a riconoscere
che Mussolini
per esempio
era un grandissimo
propagandista
un grandissimo
giornalista
dopo la seconda guerra mondiale
Salvemini
scrive un libro
proprio su Mussolini
diplomatico
in cui dice
papale papale
Mussolini
ha avuto una capacità
di far propaganda
all'Italia fascista
straordinaria
Salvemini
dice anche
Mussolini
fuori d'Italia
non poteva rompere
le teste
doveva conquistarle
e ne conquistò
un gran numero
se non tutte
in questo campo
Hitler
non può essere
paragonato
neppure a una scarpa
vecchia
di Mussolini
dopodiché
Salvemini
si dà
come scopo
nella vita
quello di spiegare
all'estero
che il fascismo
non è quello
che gli raccontano
ed essendo
uno storico
famosissimo
comincia a essere
invitato
prima in Inghilterra
poi in America
le università americane
lo invitano
un ciclo di lezioni
sulla storia
dei comuni italiani
medievali
e un ciclo
di conferenze
sull'Italia
di oggi
dove il professor
Salvemini
ci spiega
cos'è l'Italia
di oggi
ha un tale successo
che a un certo punto
cominciano a pagarlo
per fare queste conferenze
ha un impresario
che lo porta in giro
per l'America
lui scrive
questa vita
terrificante
fai una lezione
nella capitale
dell'Arkansas
poi ti mettono
su un treno
e ti portano
in Texas
e lì ti svegli
e ti portano
a fare un'altra conferenza
mi trattano
dopodiché
lo stanno a sentire
tutti
tanto che
questo è un piccolo
dettaglio affascinante
dell'Italia
di allora
il ministero
degli esteri
italiano
dà ordine
di far smettere
in qualche modo
questa cosa
prima provano a vedere
se gli americani
lo espellono
gli americani
verificano
non è comunista
quindi noi
non gli facciamo niente
a questo punto
la Farnesina
scrive
alla nostra
ambasciata
a Washington
bisogna
seguire
ogni conferenza
del professor
Salvemini
e bisogna
che in ogni conferenza
tra il pubblico
ci sia uno
dei nostri
che comincia
a disturbare
o che si alza
a fare obiezioni
questo è
l'ordine ufficiale
dalla Farnesina
all'ambasciata
italiana
negli Stati Uniti
e dall'ambasciata
ogni conferenza
di Salvemini
in qualche cittadina
sperduta
del Middle West
arriva un rapporto
a Roma
quanta gente c'era
se l'hanno applaudito
se l'hanno
ma avete mandato
uno disturbare
sì sì
mandato
Salvemini
continua
e poi
c'è anche un giornale
fascista in Italia
che rende conto
delle attività
di questo traditore
e che si augura
che la mano
benedetta
di un santo pazzo
ci liberi
del professor
Salvemini
per fortuna
la mano benedetta
insomma poi
fin lì non si arriva
però si fa anche
altro per screditarlo
negli Stati Uniti
ci sono grosse forze
che in realtà
sono amiche
dell'Italia fascista
il New York Times
è filofascista
fino in fondo
al New York Times
si fanno arrivare
delle veline
dove si spiega
che il Salvemini
è un pericoloso
terrorista
che preparava
un attentato
per far saltare
in aria
San Pietro
in Vaticano
e il New York Times
scrive
ospitiamo
questo pericoloso
terrorista
insomma
non sono tutte
rose e fiori
sta di fatto
però
che comunque
Salvemini
fa questa attività
instancabile
per anni e anni
e oggi
gli studiosi
americani
ci dicono
l'opinione pubblica
americana
era lì
in bilico
Salvemini
ha dato
una bella botta
per farla poi
traboccare
da una parte
anziché dall'altra
nel frattempo
siccome è lui
e non è il primo venuto
gli offrono
la cattedra
a Harvard
e di conseguenza
gli creano
una cattedra
di storia
della civiltà italiana
a Harvard
e lui
comincia a insegnare
storia
della civiltà italiana
a Harvard
prende la cittadinanza
americana
invecchia
sappiamo
ed el
abbiamo detto
nel 43
ha 70 anni
è cittadino americano
se ne potrebbe stare
lì tranquillo
la guerra
ormai ha convinto
gli americani
che Mussolini
va buttato giù
e che l'Italia fascista
era un bluff
Salvemini rimane lì
insegna
finché può
arriva a 75 anni
a Harvard
gli dicono
adesso però
abbi pazienza
ma vai in pensione
e dall'Italia
del dopoguerra
fra mille preoccupazioni
che ci sono nel paese
che è da ricostruire
e tutto quanto
una delle preoccupazioni
del governo italiano
e del governo
di De Gasperi
è
ma riusciamo
a far tornare
Salvemini in Italia
perché sarebbe
una tale legittimazione
della democrazia
cominciano a contattarlo
lo fanno tornare
in Italia
a 76 anni
nel 49
Salvemini
torna in Italia
e benché
abbia superato
tutti i limiti
di età
anche in Italia
gli ridanno
la cattedra
a Firenze
e Salvemini
fa la sua prima
lezione a Firenze
dopo 24 anni
cominciando così
come stavamo
dicendo l'ultima volta
due parole
ancora su come
vede Salvemini
questa Italia
del dopoguerra
da un lato
è ammiratissimo
a parte che dice
una cosa fantastica
sono passati di moda
i cappelli delle donne
come sono bella
i miei tempi
avevano tutti questi
cappelli enormi
adesso sono bellissime
senza cappello
poi vede la ricostruzione
ed è affascinato
quel meraviglioso
formicaio
umano
che sono
i contadini
italiani
dice
li vede ancora
solo i contadini
è un meridionale
dell'ottocento
ma comunque
del resto
l'Italia è ancora
per metà
un paese contadino
in quegli anni
questo paese
si riprenderà
con una rapidità
che nessuno
avrebbe mai
sospettato
il formicaio
in piena
efficienza
però
però poi anche lì
si è fatto forse
qualche illusione
alla fine qualcosa
che lo delude
lo trova
per esempio
trova che al sud
non è cambiato
fondamentalmente
niente
e comincia a pensare
che l'unica soluzione
è che il nord
e il sud
si devono fare insieme
non ci crede più
che il sud
si tiri fuori da solo
e allora dice
no adesso noi
quel che dobbiamo fare
è spiegare
a quelli del nord
che devono darsi da fare
anche per il sud
perché
sembra strano
ma anche in quell'Italia
degli anni 40
al nord
c'è chi dice
ma perché
dovremmo preoccuparcene
sentite ancora questa
che lo vogliano
o no i settentrionali
essi sono attaccati
ai terroni
come il busto
è attaccato
alle gambe
così il pugliese
salvemini
bisogna dunque
ripetere
nell'Italia settentrionale
anche a chi
non vuol sentire
e sono sempre
molti
che i nordici
debbono occuparsi
non solo
di se stessi
ma anche
dei sudici
se non vogliono
che finisca male
dopodiché
quella lì
è l'Italia
di De Gasperi
di Togliatti
della DC
e del Partito Comunista
e Salvemini
come potete capire
non ci si trova
tanto bene
nella politica
dell'Italia
di allora
in questo paese
di clericali
mezzo comunisti
e di comunisti
mezzo clericali
esprimere
una franca opinione
è diventata
roba da manicomio
nel diario
scrive
ormai credo
solo più
in Critone
di Platone
e nel discorso
della montagna
muore nel
e proprio
in punto di morte
che fa quella rivelazione
dice ma guarda
ho pensato
tutta la vita
al suicidio
e sono arrivato
84 anni
e poi
chi era lì
con lui
dice
ha passato
gli ultimi momenti
a cercare
di capire
cosa gli stava
succedendo
a fare la storia
della propria morte
in un certo senso
a riferire
cosa si prova
e le sue ultime parole
che però sono tristi
ma comunque
le sue ultime parole
sono
non c'è differenza
tra la morte
e la vita
non si può
fissare il passaggio
è tutta una cosa
non c'è differenza
tra la morte
e la vita
la morte
è dolore
grazie
grazie mille
a domani